y que construyan las instituciones que necesitamos.
Pero no será solo una formación académica.
También aprenderán a ser líderes
y a desarrollar sus habilidades como emprendedores.
Piensen en esto como en la Ivy League de África,
pero en lugar de ser aceptados por sus exámenes de conocimiento
o por cuánto dinero tengan
o de qué familia vengan,
el criterio principal para entrar a esta universidad
será el potencial que tengan
para transformar África.
Pero lo que hemos creado es solo un grupo de instituciones.
No podemos transformar África nosotros solos.
Mi esperanza
es que florezcan muchas más
instituciones locales africanas
y que esas instituciones se unan
con la visión común de desarrollar
la próxima generación de líderes africanos,
la cuarta generación,
y que les enseñen este mensaje común:
creen trabajos, construyan nuestras instituciones.
Nelson Mandela dijo una vez:
"De vez en cuando,
una generación está llamada a la grandeza.
Uds. pueden ser esa gran generación".
Creo que si identificamos y cultivamos cuidadosamente
a la siguiente generación de líderes africanos,
entonces esta cuarta generación está llamada
a ser la generación más grande que África
y el mundo entero hayan visto jamás.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)